the planet is heating up but what does
that mean for us in low-lying coastal
areas it means rising sea levels and a
loss of home as people relocate to
higher ground half of the village has
been keeping sea level rise and so
there's been relocation sir in frozen
areas it has disrupted Thor cycles and
led to mass starvation among reindeer
threatening farmers and indigenous
people's livelihoods
[Music]
thoughtfully from Fedora Darien addict
for me and thumb or the full of guitars
batik is professor laying it in your
pool boy Yin for coral reefs like the
Great Barrier Reef it has resulted in
coral bleaching and ecosystem loss
[Music]
in places like Germany farmers have
suffered unprecedented drought
in the students lunch written as boost
and diesel extreme the hi monitors who
finish paying to Utley global warming
also increases extreme weather like
destructive wildfires in California
and devastating flooding can be at nom
[Music]
although the impacts vary from place to
place
almost everywhere climate change means a
loss of home and livelihood
those speak different languages and come
from different cultures but we are
connected to the left and we are
connected by the ocean
[Applause]